[Musique]
j'ai mangé mon jumeau dans le ventre de
ma mère non je parle pas de moi mais je
suis sûr que vous avez déjà entendu ce
genre d'histoire non attendez
apparemment ce serait votre frère jumeau
que vous aurez absorbé
quand vous étiez dans le ventre de votre
mère voilà comme ça maintenant tout le
monde en a entendu parler ça c'était
grégorano vous souvenez il est venu nous
parler de son syndrome de Marfan et bah
figurez-vous que c'est pas le seul à
avoir mangé son jumeau je sens que je
vous ai
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le jumeau cannibale le jumeau parasite
sympa comme petit nom qu'est-ce qui se
cache derrière ces mots un petit peu
terrifiant est-ce qu'il y a vraiment des
gens qui mangent leurs jumeaux dans le
ventre de leur mère en fait si cette
expression ressemble plus à un titre de
film d'horreur qui a un terme
scientifique il y a une raison d'abord
parce qu'elle recouvre plusieurs
réalités des jumelles des jumeaux on va
dire une grossesse gémellaire ça fera
plus stylée qu'est-ce que c'est bah déjà
de base il y a deux possibilités soit il
y a deux ovules différents qui sont
fécondés et qui se développent chacun de
leur côté là on parle de jumeaux
dizygote on appelle ça aussi des faux
jumeaux soit il y a un seul ovule qui
est fécondé cet ovule il va devenir un
neuf et cette oeuf au lieu de donner un
seul embryon comme la plupart du temps
il va se diviser et donner deux embryons
qui vont ensuite se développer aussi
chacun de leur côté ça c'est les jumeaux
monozygotes les vrais jumeaux et ensuite
pour la petite histoire dans ce dernier
cas de figure les jumeaux soit ils
peuvent avoir chacun leur propre
placenta soit être relié au même
placenta en gros le placenta c'est une
espèce de qui est collé à la paroi de
l'utérus et à laquelle le fœtus est
relié par le cordon ombilical ça lui
permet notamment d'aller chercher dans
le sang de la mer tout ce dont il a
besoin pour se développer et d'y rejeter
tout ce dont il a pas besoin ces déchets
en fait c'est à la fois son frigo et ses
toilettes si vous voulez alors oui c'est
dégueu mais bon c'est même pas encore un
vrai bébé on va pas commencer à le juger
un autre truc ils peuvent aussi partager
la même poche amniotique ou avoir chacun
leur la poche amniotique c'est ce qu'on
appelle aussi la poche des eaux c'est
cette espèce de sac plein de liquide
dans lequel le foetus est enfermé à
l'intérieur de l'utérus pendant toute la
grossesse c'est sa chambre en fait donc
les jumeaux soit ils ont chacun la leur
soit ils sont dans la même et soit ils
ont leur frigo WC personnel soit il
partage le même tout ça ça dépend du
moment auquel l'oeuf c'est divisé en
deux embryons plus ils sont séparés tôt
après la fécondation plus ils sont
indépendants et plus ils sont séparés
tard plus ils partagent leurs affaires
d'ailleurs si la division elle arrive
tard ça peut donner ce qu'on appelle des
jumeaux conjoints des jumeaux fusionnés
que vous connaissez sûrement sous le nom
de siamois alors vous allez me dire
d'accord mais c'est pas le sujet déjà
parlé mieux parce que sinon ça va mal se
mettre et puis OK vous avez raison c'est
pas complètement le sujet mais un peu
quand même vous allez voir que
l'histoire qui nous intéresse ou plutôt
les histoires qui nous intéressent en
fait parce que cette histoire de manger
son jumeau dans le landes de sa mère ça
peut être utilisé pour parler de cas
très différents elles ont toutes un
point commun pour les jumeaux fusionnés
les Siamois dont on vient de parler à la
base il y a deux embryons et il se passe
quelque chose à un moment de leur
développement qui fait que ça se déroule
pas de façon classique et bah là c'est
pareil dans les histoires de jumeaux
cannibales mais je vous propose qu'on
arrête une bonne fois pour toute
d'employés stermatros c'est aussi à
chaque fois deux embryons qui se
développent pas comme d'habitude l'un
des deux surtout mais ça peut avoir des
conséquences sur l'autre pour bien
comprendre de quoi on parle je vous
propose qu'on prenne des cas concrets on
va commencer par les cas les plus
courants et on finira par des histoires
beaucoup plus rares donc beaucoup plus
complexes dans un premier temps
revenons-en à la migragomano dans
l'épisode de vous voyez dont je vous ai
mis le lien dans la description il parle
d'une tumeur 10 embryonnaire qu'on a
découvert dans son cervelet le cervelet
c'est pas de la charcuterie c'est une
partie du cerveau qui se trouve là donc
le médecin ont trouvé une tumeur c'est à
dire un amas de cellules la ligne ou
bénigne en référence bénigne dans son
cerveau jusque là on voit bien mais quel
rapport avec un jumeau parce que cette
tumeur elle s'est formée à partir de
tissu embryonnaire c'est à dire les
mêmes que ceux qu'on trouve au moment où
un embryon commence à se développer ces
tumeur on les appelle des dix embryomes
ou encore des tératomes ce qui veut dire
tumeur monstre décidément on est doué
pour trouver des termes qui mettent bien
à l'aise on les a appelés comme ça
précisément parce qu'on pensait que
c'était une sorte de jumeau monstrueux
qui se développait à l'intérieur du
corps de son frère ou de sa soeur alors
qu'avec le recul en réalité on s'est
rendu compte que c'était juste des
cellules qui proliférait de façon
anarchique mais ce qui a entretenu ce
mythe un peu monstrueux c'est que ces
tumeur c'est kystes si vous voulez ils
peuvent contenir des tissus immatures
c'est à dire qu'ils se sont pas
développés mais ils peuvent aussi des
tissus qui se sont développés au point
qu'on y retrouve parfois des ongles des
poils des dents des os etc je vous mets
pas les photos pour préserver les gens
que ça pourrait déranger mais si vous
tapez terreaux sur Google Images vous
allez être servi comme d'hab vérifier
les sources parce qu'il y a pas mal de
fake il y a même un cas d'écrit en 2017
qui parle d'un kyste découvert au niveau
de l'ovaire d'une patiente de saison et
qui contenait du cervelet la boucle est
bouclée ces kystes on les retrouve le
plus souvent au niveau des ovaires comme
là ou des testicules mais aussi souvent
au niveau sacro-coxygien c'est-à-dire à
la hauteur entre le sacrum et le coccyx
juste au dessus de l'arrêt du cul pour
ce qu'on va faire latin mais il peut y
en avoir aussi à plein d'autres endroits
y compris au niveau du cerveau voilà
donc premier niveau des kystes avec à
l'intérieur des tissus embryonnaires
plus ou moins matures plus ou moins
développée voire carrément des poils des
dents des eaux de l'ongle etc c'est des
choses qui existent même si la science
sépare encore vraiment expliqué pourquoi
alors actuelle mais parlons 10 bac
pacunda axé un petit péruvien il a trois
ans en 2012 quand ses parents l'amènent
à l'hôpital parce qu'il a le ventre
gonflé quelques heures plus tard une
équipe de chirurgiens retire de son
estomac un fœtus de près de 25 cm pour
pas loin de 700 g c'est à dire
l'équivalent d'un fœtus de 5 à 6 mois de
grossesse qui lui retire de l'estomac
donc là j'entends des ah bah voilà il a
mangé son jumeau le gamin
sauf que non isback n'a mangé personne
c'est ce qu'on appelle un cas de fœtus
infetu un fœtus dans un fœtus et c'est
aussi une anomalie du développement
embryonnaire là pour le coup
effectivement il y a deux fœtus mais il
y en a un qui s'est développé à
l'intérieur de l'autre on sait pas
pourquoi mais il est là dans le cas du
petit bac le fœtus il avait des eaux des
cheveux et des yeux mais pas de coeur
pas de poumon pas de cerveau et pas
d'intestin dans un même ordre d'idées
deux ans plus tôt une petite fille aînée
à Hong Kong avec deux fœtus dans le
ventre pas dans l'estomac donc elles
n'ont plus elle mangeait personne et pas
dans l'utérus donc elle n'était pas
enceinte de ses frères et soeurs comme
on l'a lu dans la presse à l'époque ils
étaient entre sa rate et son rein gauche
à la base en faisant des examens à la
petite fille juste après sa naissance
les médecins ils ont repéré une masse de
4,5 cm de diamètre à peu près et ils ont
décidé de l'opérer pour la retirer et
ils ont constaté que la masse en
question elle était en fait composée de
deux petites masses dans un sac deux
fœtus avec chacun un cordon
ombilical sont reliés à quelque chose
qui ressemblait à un placenta deux fœtus
avec des os des muscles des cartilages
des bras des jambes une colonne
vertébrale une ébauche d'organes
génitaux mais pas de cœur des
inspecteurs des impôts
qui ne se sont pas développés
normalement et heureusement pour la
petite fille qui a survécu a priori sans
cesse donc là on est dans un cas de
figure encore plus rare des sortes de
triplés si on veut mais la localisation
ça reste dans l'abdomen comme dans la
plupart des cas mais on peut trouver des
foetus in fétus dans d'autres parties du
corps y compris un testicule ou dans le
cerveau pour citer que ces exemples il y
a même une vieille publication
scientifique qui décrit un cas où il y a
eu 5 foetus retrouvés dans une tumeur
cérébrale est-ce que c'était vraiment
des fœtus in fétus ou des terre-atumes
la publication parle vraiment de foetus
mais comme ça date un peu
bref mais parfois ça arrive aussi qu'on
en découvre chez des adultes parce que
ils se plaignent de maux de tête de
douleurs abdominales etc alors donc on a
dit qu'on arrêtait de parler de jumeaux
cannibales et on a bien vu pourquoi ça
arrive à rien mais là peut-être que vous
vous dites quelque chose du genre
elle a quand même le coup du jumeau
parasite il y a quelque chose quand même
non je vois ce que vous voulez dire le
côté le jumeau qui se développe à
l'intérieur de l'autre jumeau je suis
pas d'accord avec vous on va en reparler
mais je vois ceci dit le terme de
jumeaux parasites il est aussi utilisé
pour désigner un autre cas de figure
encore et là on va parler de la petite
laque schmie Tatma la Schmitt Atma c'est
une petite fille né en Inde en 2005 avec
la particularité d'avoir quatre bras et
4 jambes en fait son cas se situe un
petit peu entre le foetus in fétus et
les jumeaux fusionnés les Siamois sauf
que là c'est quelque chose de très
précis qui s'appelle lischio pagus ça
vient du mot ischion qui est la partie
inférieure dans des eaux du bassin que
vous voyez là et de pagos qui veut dire
fixer en réalité la chemise n'a pas
vraiment quatre bras et quatre jambes
elle a membres à elle et ce d'un autre
fœtus qui s'est développé pendant la
grossesse ceux de sa jumelle donc qui
relie à elle par le bassin mais dont le
développement a pas été complet
puisqu'elle a ni tête ni thorax mais
uniquement un bassin de bras et de
jambes donc là encore une anomalie du
développement personne a mangé personne
et la chenille n'est pas non plus une
divinité contrairement à ce que les gens
sont villages ont cru quand ils l'ont vu
d'ailleurs la chemise c'est le nom d'une
déesse hindou qui est représentée avec
quatre bras après une opération de plus
de 24 heures la petite fille a été
débarrassée de ses membres entre autres
et de la colonne vertébrale de sa
jumelle qui avait fusionné avec la
sienne l'équipe de chirurgiens qui l'a
opéré a aussi fait en sorte de lui
laisser les organes qui fonctionnaient
bien et de retirer les autres qui lui a
permis non seulement de survivre mais
aussi de pouvoir marcher parce que
jusque là elle rampait voilà les
ischiopagus ça peut avoir des formes
assez différentes il y avait aussi le
cas d'un autre jeune indien qui
s'appelait Deepak pas Swan qui avait été
pas mal médiatisé et il y a plusieurs
autres cas qui ont été décrits dans la
littérature scientifique dont un certain
nombre ressemblait pas mal à vous avez
ici à moi relié par le bassin d'ailleurs
le terme est aussi parfois utilisé pour
décrire ce genre de cas bref vous avez
compris tout ça ça a toujours beaucoup
intrigué beaucoup fait parler beaucoup
fait travailler l'imaginaire et du coup
beaucoup raconté de conneries d'ailleurs
avec tout le respect que je dois aux
divinités j'ai les Grecs on racontait
Catena était sorti du crâne de Zeus qui
avait demandé qu'on lui ouvre en deux
parce qu'il avait des grosses migraines
pardon mais ça ressemble quand même pas
mal à une histoire de fœtus infectue ou
de Terra Tom qui serait arrivé jusqu'à
nous après pas mal de bouche à oreille
non donc pour reprendre les termes
vraiment pas ouf dont on parle depuis le
début le jumeau cannibale ce serait
celui à l'intérieur duquel ce sont
développés des cellules embryonnaires
des cellules qui formeraient dans
l'imaginaire des gens le second jumeau
qui se développe à l'intérieur du
premier donc le jumeau parasite sauf
qu'en réalité on l'a déjà dit soyons
très clairs personne ne mange personne
dans le ventre de sa mère et personne
n'est responsable de la disparition
d'une sœur jumelle ou d'un frère jumeau
c'est juste des histoires la division
cellulaire et de développement
embryonnaire un embryon qui se développe
pas normalement et qui va éventuellement
se loger là où on n'attend pas donc il y
a pas de jumeaux cannibales il y a pas
un terroriser les gens avec ce genre
d'histoire et encore moins les
culpabiliser personne ne survit au
détriment de son frère ou de sa sœur il
y a juste des embryons qui se
développent normalement parce qu'ils
sont viables et d'autres qui sont pas
viables c'est important de faire
attention à ce qu'on raconte surtout les
professionnels de santé parce qu'il y a
des gens que ça peut affecter
profondément par exemple je me souviens
de l'histoire de Jenny Kavanagh une
femme de 45 ans à qui on avait retiré
une masse au niveau d'un ovaire quand
elle a raconté tout ça à la presse elle
avait dit ça lorsque j'ai montré la
photo à ma mère ça l'a rendu vraiment
triste elle en parle comme si c'était
mon frère jumeau moi j'essaye de pas
trop y penser parce que je veux pas être
triste pour être honnête je me suis
sentie mal en le voyant pour la première
fois parce que vu sa taille et son poids
il ressemblait déjà à un bébé il y a un
psychothérapeute allemand qui sait
penché sur ce genre de question et qui
estime qu'un embryon sur 10 à un jumeau
qui disparaît en cours de grossesse et
que ça pourrait avoir des conséquences
sur la survivante ou le survivant au
point de développer ce qu'on appelle le
syndrome du jumeau perdu parfois même
sans savoir qu'un jumeau a disparu
encore de grossesse alors imaginez en
plus si cette personne là s'imagine
qu'elle a bouffé son jumeau ou sa
jumelle ou que l'autre est morte et
qu'elle est là survécu parce qu'elle a
pris toute la bouffe ou je sais pas quoi
c'est hyper traumatisant alors attention
le coup de la bouffe là c'est un truc
qui peut arriver quand deux fœtus
partage le même place inta vous souvenez
comme on a dit au début ça peut arriver
qui est une inégalité dans la
répartition de la circulation sanguine
donc de la bouffe ça s'appelle le
syndrome transfuseur transfusé c'est
rare mais surtout ça n'a absolument rien
à voir avec tous les cas dont on vient
de parler et puis en plus ça peut être
fatale aux deux foetus voilà évidemment
on est loin d'avoir fait le tour de la
question j'aurais pu aussi vous parler
des chimères par exemple les chimères
c'est un peu l'inverse en fait c'est
quand il y a deux fécondations donc il
devrait y avoir deux embryons mais qui
fusionnent et au final ça donne un seul
bébé qui a deux ADN différents notamment
mais c'est pas tout à fait le sujet par
contre si ça vous intéresse n'hésitez
pas à me le dire je peux en reparler
dans une prochaine vidéo bon et comme
d'habitude je vous ai mis dans la
description de la vidéo des liens vers
les différents cas dont je vous ai parlé
je vous préviens c'est des publications
scientifiques donc ça s'embarrasse assez
peu de sentiments il y a des photos
graphiques sans disclaimer mais comme je
suis sympa je vous ai mis un petit
attention photo à côté des liens en
question pour que vous soyez prévenu DTC
c'est fini pour aujourd'hui on se
retrouve très vite pour de nouvelles
vidéos d'ici là prenez soin de vous et
prenez soin des autres mettez-vous bien
et surtout portez-vous bien
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]